it's wednesday february 10th
uncle joey's joint is brought to you by
draftkings
[__] tremendous listen everybody
needs money on valentine's day
it starts today right now download the
draftkings app
and let's get the party started we got
some great games that tonight
but let's talk about what's happening
this weekend sunday night is valentine's
day and for la
versus the denver game draftkings has
got some [__] chocolate for you
if you're like me you're looking for an
opportunity to get better odds correct
well look no [__] further if you
place a bet on sunday night's basketball
game
you will single-handedly lower the over
under
that's some sweet [__] love right
there for every thousand players who bet
the over on sunday night's game
the line will drop by one point did i
tell you draftkings is the best
and the best part about it is even if
the line lowers
the odds remain at even money that's
[__] right
it's called hammering the over and you
could double your [__] money
this weekend right now download the
top-rated draftking sportsbook app now
and use code joey when you sign up the
ham of the over
on sunday night's basketball game when
la
takes on denver listen a thousand people
that bet the over in sunday's game
that the line will decrease by one point
for every thousand people that bet the
over
yes this is your chance to improve the
odds of hitting
so tell your friends family the priest
the [__] mailman
that this is a team effort hammer the
over and improve your odds of doubling
your money
that's promo code joey for a limited
time only at draftkings
sportsbook and here's the legal [__]
part i got to tell you
you got to be 21 older go get the
[__] whistle new jersey indiana
michigan virginia only
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
sportsbooks for details if you have a
gambling problem
get it together call 1-800 gambler or in
indiana 1-800
with it or in virginia 888 532
3500 but if you're cool let's [__]
play hamilton over
with code joey on draftkings download
the app
right now the joint is also brought to
you by
stamps.com [__] tremendous you don't
have to leave the [__] house let's
face it
taking trips to the post office saying
how you want to spend your time
that's why i recommend stamps.com my
wife uses it to send out the hoodies the
mugs the patches
she's been doing it for eight nine years
you can send letters packages
anytime anywhere right from your
computer and you pay a lot less with
discounted rates from you
sps and ups and more stamps.com has
saved businesses
thousands of hours and tons of money get
the services at the post office and ups
all in one place your house plus
big discounts listen it saves you time
and money it's very easy stamps.com
brings the post office and ups
right to your computer if you got the
business this
is a must-have so stop wasting time go
to the post office
and go to stamps.com instead of their no
risk don't you don't need to go to a
post office
with the promo code joey you get a
special offer that includes a four week
trial
plus free postage and a digital scale
no long-term commitment to contract just
go to stamps.com
click on the microphone on the top of
the home page and type in joey
that stamps dot com promo code joey
you're not gonna
go to the post office again people
coughing on your [__] neck and [__]
no more no more post office go to
stance.com
use code joey and get a special offer
that includes a four week trial
free postage and a digital scale
stamps.com
click joey the joint is also brought to
you by
cbd lion my [__] savior during this
[__] surgery
from the gummy bears to the the roll-on
to the kinesiology tape to the i mean
listen
they just cover all the bases and they
tell you what's in the product
this isn't a [__] mystery product go
to cbdlion.com right now
look over what they have read learn
read you have pain you have anxiety
whatever you have
they will help you this product has
helped me tremendously
during this surgery i have the
kinesiology tape on
right now under my [__] stocking so
cbd lion is the way to go go to
cbdlion.com right now and press in
church
joey get 20 off and it gets delivered
right to your house
you don't got to deal with no guy at
some [__] store that don't know dick
about dick
that's it and that's that go to
cbdlion.com
let's get ready to start this
[__] party here
oh nelly it's time for uncle joey's
joint [__]
hey look who it is
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday
february 10th a beautiful [__]
day to be alive
thank you for watching uncle joey's
joint i'm sorry about monday's podcast
we didn't talk about the [__] super
bowl we got caught up on patience that
morning
i was thinking about patience and uh we
didn't talk about the super bowl a lot
of other things that were on my mind
today i want to talk to you about guys
about something that i
feel that i'm not doing you any favors
by
uh by telling you these things
especially the younger comics and people
who are starting as electricians
or or [__] carpenters or if you're an
apprentice
or if you're starting your own business
i want you to remember something okay
when i got into comedy
i wanted to change my life when i got
into comedy
and right now this this is it i'm
telling you i'm i mean
i've been in comedy clubs 30 years it's
official this week
this is the week when i started working
at wits end in westminster colorado
[__] 30 years ago so i've been going
to comedy clubs
when i got into comedy at first it was a
slow the first two years
it was a very slow progression i didn't
know what i was doing
i was feeling myself around and in
retrospect i shouldn't even count those
two years
but i do i say the truth because it
doesn't really matter
it's just two extra years that i was
just [__] around i didn't know
how to even get started but once i got
what i was doing
i committed and when i committed i
[__] committed
you know i was all in but i still had
sort of a life
you know i still had sort of a life i'm
in boulder
i still you know dated girls i knew i
didn't want to get married when i
committed
i committed to not get married i didn't
even want a girlfriend
i didn't want a girlfriend i just wanted
to you know sleep for people from time
to time if i was lucky whatever
that's it i didn't want a girlfriend you
know i knew i was a [__] broke comic
who wants to date a broke [__] comic
you no so
i when i first left boulder i still had
like little friends and stuff like that
that i did things with you know i went
to nugget games
i would go to cu games i would go to
concerts i would go
to the fox theater you know i did [__]
like that and then when i lived in
seattle i was part of a crew you know i
was with josh wolf and mark madison and
just a bunch of us running around and
even up there we went to a couple
seahawk games and
and [__] like that when i moved to la
and i got into the comedy store i knew
from my insecurities i just knew i
wasn't as good as everybody else
i looked around la and all the [__] i
heard about la and i went to all the
comedy clubs and i went home and i have
a long talk of myself
that if i'm gonna last here i gotta
commit
into this 150 and when i mean 150
i mean i got to eat sleep and think
[__] comedy
and that's great that's what you know
that's what commitment is
but i think when i got to la i did it a
little bit too much like i just got into
it i still remember
you know i got there meeting ralphie and
basically you know i slept in different
places
you know i would sleep in my car
whatever and then i would walk the
ralphies in the afternoon
and i would [__] we would just sit
there and write jokes
you know and then as i got more time in
i started auditioning and then the
[__] i got the acting bug and i want
to know everything about acting i mean i
had watched a thousand [__] movies
you know i know everything about [__]
movies i love movies so i had watched
everything about movies
but i needed to learn how to act i
thought in my mind i needed to learn how
to act
so i got into [__] uh you know
acting class and then you know i started
going on the [__] road in 98 and
you know one thing led to another i
became a working comic and i'm
very proud of that fact but i think i
took it a little too far
as a working comic because i gave up
all the things that brought me joy
the only thing that i took with me into
comedy was my drug habit
that's it that's all i had it was drugs
and comedy
women weren't even in the mix for me at
that point i mean
this is square business when i got into
that [__] comedy store
i went nuts i didn't know i was very
inferior i knew that you know i could be
out of there any day i told you guys
that
there were nights i would bomb and i
would cry in the car on the way home
because i'd say to myself this is the
last time i'll be in there especially
after that [__] bombing you know but
again i got so involved with comedy that
when i moved to l.a i was 248 pounds
dude is that on the big side at that
time if you just saw me you would go
jesus joey
you look like a million [__] bucks i
had big shoulders you know
in seattle i hit the bag i lifted from
time to time i played basketball
you know i was involved with different
things when i moved to seattle when i
moved to la
the competition was so fierce and i knew
i had to go in so deep that i gave every
like i said i just
little by little you know all the things
that brought me joy going to the movies
you know all those little things i just
cut them out it was
the money i had was either going to be
used for a plane ticket
or for cocaine rent or child support all
that other [__] went away and one of the
things i got rid of
and you guys know this for a fact was
football like i used to [__] grind
lee all the time like what'd you do all
day
sunday i watched both games who watches
two [__] football games
on a [__] sunday when you're 32 years
old you have so much to do
even i gave up [__] football watching
football
watching baseball watching basketball
you guys know how much i love basketball
i knew [__] everything about
basketball
in 95 i [__] took
the houston rockets that's when orlando
magic had [__] shack
i knew everything about [__] sports i
worked for a sports betting service
from 93 to 95 i did three years on the
sports betting service
i knew players draft picks who the
quarterback was the coach's wife who his
girlfriend was i knew everything about
[__] sports
that's what us as guys do when i got
into comedy
i even told football to go [__] itself
because you can't sit around and watch
football you need to write
you know i had programmed myself that i
was beating myself up that much
that i even stopped watching football i
stopped watching basketball
yeah i went to in 23 years
rogan took me to a laker game when he
was on fear factor
him and doug stanhope we went to the
[__] uh
a laker game and i went to the laker
game i think with my wife
and another family i went to two laker
games in 23 years
i went to maybe 15 dodger games
i couldn't tell you the lineup i just
went to take my uncle because he was a
baseball fan
so after i reconnected with my uncle in
i started taking him to dodger games
before 2009 i didn't go to any [__]
dodger games
so you got to remember from 98 to
2006 i didn't take a break
and i also got up to 418
[__] pounds like even my fitness
even my health i didn't even care about
my [__] health
the first time i went to a doctor was
when i met this poor girl my wife
and she forced me to go to a doctor for
sleep apnea and even though i had
insurance and everything
i forgot all like i didn't do anything i
used to do
when i was in a hotel room on a sunday
when i used to work sunday i think i
worked sundays up to 99.
i would not watch football i would turn
it off and i'd be [__] writing
and that was all good you know for 20
[__] three years in [__] la
i didn't have much of a life i i turned
my life into a
it was all built around comedy if i went
to a party it was because it was a
comedy party
or a movie invited me to a party i had
worked on a show
you know and i went to a party you know
sometimes i just went i didn't want to
[__] go to a party
i just want to take my wife out on a
date like the last one we went to was
i'm dying up here
had a season finale and i did two
episodes and i took it to that part you
know
i didn't do anything that was normal
nothing like that
and i had friends like i had ari and i
had the duncan and i had you know
eddie bravo me and eddie went to a
couple dodger games with the kids
you know i had all that stuff but
something was missing from my life
when i moved to jersey i made plans in
my mind that
i had to change my life like if i move
to jersey
this [__] that i'm doing this my social
life
has to definitely [__] change like
something has to come of this
and uh you know the pandemic came
i called jimmy florentine uh
jimmy florentine's sister-in-law trish
florentine
sold me the house and i was very happy
i had my friends up north you know i was
gonna start hanging out with them
and then one day jimmy says to me i
don't know if you know this but on
sundays
we do football you know i don't know
who's going to show up
this year because of cobit but you're
welcome
to come over we open up the windows they
have an air filter they
open up the back air and everybody's
social distances and we watch football
like eight or nine guys
so doing the pandemic you know i'm like
like
i don't know much you know i don't
really want to watch a football game
but i'll go over there and i started
going over there and i started going
over there
until halftime and then i would stay to
the third quarter
and then i would stay to the fourth
quarter and then i would stay to the
beginning of the next game you know and
then i would stay for [__] till
halftime
and you know pretty soon i would be
there and i would watch the first two
games of the day
at jimmy florentines with his friends
his childhood [__] friends and all
his family
and i would sit there and i would take
edibles and [__] giggle
and trust me the first three or four
weeks i would just sit in the corner
paranoid saying when am i gonna get
[__] covered you know i was scared of
getting covered
but these guys are all clean like they
all you know wear masks and they're all
legit during the week
there was no reason to be scared we did
the whole season without a whole [__]
thing knock on wood
we did the whole [__] season without
somebody and i think i missed
three weeks like the two two weeks of
surgery
after the surgery was the only two or
three sundays i missed
i never missed a sunday i went every
[__] sunday
and every and let me tell you something
how much it helped me
just doing that not doing comedy on
sunday
when we're over there on sunday those
guys don't give a [__] that i wasn't
and the many saints in newark they don't
give a [__] i was in spider-man 2.
they don't give a [__] that i sold out a
theater they don't give a [__] about
nothing
they're they'll bet and watch [__]
football and crack jokes and say the
craziest things you've ever heard in
your life
and i loved it it actually brought me
back the reason why i'm back
is from going over there on sundays you
know when i
before we went i went over there jimmy
came up to me he's like listen
there's some guys that are kind of
they're crazy they say some [__] up
[__] and i'm like
dog i'm from [__] jersey you know i
remember leaving there and him calling
me going
were they a little too heavy for you and
i'm like dog
i'm so happy i went to your house
because just knowing those
type of people still exist and la those
people don't exist
just knowing that those people still
exist that i left jersey
and i was missing something in l.a and i
come back and jimmy florentines throws
me into his [__]
sunday football i mean it was it was
like being a little kid in the candy
store
they got the pizzas they got the wings
they got the shrimp
they got they got everything but it's
not that it's the camaraderie
they [__] they gamble you know so i
got into they were they're all on
[__] draftkings
we're all on draftkings [__] around
every week this week i did not make a
[__] bet for the super bowl
i did like the total when i spoke to
draftkings and my agent on thursday
last week and when i got off the phone
my agent calls me back and she goes
draftkings want to know
who you like michael i'm not betting the
the team
it's too hard to bet the team i'm gonna
bet the total
i like the total because my in my mind
i thought that exactly what happened
happened
in my mind i thought that either they
were gonna get to brady
and homie was gonna score a couple
touchdowns but i didn't think it was
going to be an all-out war
you know what i'm saying like an all-out
[__] one touchdown another touchdown
i knew one of the defenses was going to
get to one of the quarterbacks
to be honest i didn't think it was going
to be mahone's i thought that brady
was just a little too old [__] he
[__] uh
you know changed my [__] mind and my
perspective quick
i would hit the pool this week at
jimmy's i won the second half i want a
hundred bucks
so you know it was perfect i put 30
bucks you know it was those things when
was the last time i played a pool
you know the last time i put five
dollars in a square
yeah [__] 30 years ago like all these
little things this is what i want you to
understand
that when you get into something i don't
care how much you love it
you still got to keep up your social
things
whatever your social activities are away
from that
you know listen i love comedians i love
being around them
they're [__] nuts but this break has
done me
wonders and going over there on sundays
was the start of it you know
i got the people who knocked my anxiety
out and my fears
were two men it was rich boss
and jimmy florentine when i got here
when i was in the summer set i would
have to meet
rich like every other day we would meet
at a bagel place and i'd sit outside
and the whole time i'd be [__]
shaking i'd have anxiety
i was scared of the news but when i saw
jimmy and his family
and how they got together and everybody
was cool and everything was
i was like [__] it i guess that we're
gonna be cool and every monday morning i
would wake up and swallow
do i have a sore throat nothing nothing
nothing
i mean the house is clean it's just a
great [__] time with guys
but what i'm trying to say to you here
is no matter what you get involved in
never forget yourself i got to be honest
with you that was my biggest mistake
when i got into comedy that is why i am
burnt out on [__] comedy right now
that is why i said those things on
sunday that i said
because when i went in i went in i've
been doing what i was doing
since 1994 i have
not [__] stopped and from
98 to 2020
i did not have that social [__] life
i did not have that social life
yes i had friends and yes i had a
podcast
and yes i went to that store but those
little simple little things is what i
was missing and what i wanted
that's all i wanted i wanted to have
regular [__] people around me again i
i got sick and tired of hearing about
instagram friends and
how many facebook followers do you have
and how many twitter followers do
nobody in my [__] neighborhood gives
two frenchmen's [__]
that i've been in the movie not one
[__] person
in this neighborhood that said to me hey
can we take a [__] picture
not one of them my man frank across the
street
every once in a while he'll go was that
you i saw a brick chrysler show on
netflix and i go yeah i get lucky from
time to time
they don't give a frenchman's [__] it's
not like l.a was that everything is
based off
what you have on social media or who
you're hanging out with
or he's friends with chappelle yeah what
the [__] is wrong with you why can't you
just be [__] normal
i'm sorry about that but the moral of
the story is
i forgot who the [__] i was i forgot
those little things
going to football just to go into
somebody's house and
watching football and if i'm not there i
go to my other buddy's house joe rail
and i go over there and i smoke a number
over there with him and i watch [__]
tv
you know just for an hour he watches
shows about real estate and [__]
i don't give a [__] we're not talking
about
an audition or what a club did to you or
you know last weekend in tampa i don't
want to hear that [__] no more
it was just to the point where i
couldn't hear it no more i just got
i don't know i don't know how to explain
it i still love [__] comedy i still
love
watching it i was watching rod and white
last night dying my ass off
from the [__] uh when they all did
the show together the four [__]
amigos whatever the [__] they are
ron white had me dying but my love for
comedy
like is still there i just right now at
this time
i think i'm just [__] burnt out and
sure who's not gonna be burnt out
i gave everything i [__] had to this
[__] thing
i didn't go in there to [__] around i
didn't go in there to get a [__] deal
i didn't get a [__] deal
to 2000 [__] 17. everybody was
getting deals in 2000 2001 2002.
nobody was talking to me when nobody
remembers is that
in 2009 i quit comedy
i was like [__] it i'm not gonna i'm not
i'm not at the store anymore i got joe
rogan who takes me on the road he goes
on the road enough
i'll go on the road with him i'll do 20
15 minutes
and i'll get a job during the week and
i'll [__] let my friends like greg
garcia people like that
put me in their tv shows and i'll get
insurance and that's what what i was
gonna do
i was burnt the [__] out nobody wanted
to talk to me nobody nobody ever said
two words to me about stand up this
whole career started when i told the
story
on beauty and the beast about mugging a
hooker and lighthearted wigging on fire
then all i did 20 [__] movies nobody
would say a [__] word to me
not a word to me nobody would come up to
me ace but no nothing
all of a sudden i go on a [__]
podcast that nobody really listened to
and i said that i [__] little [__]
hooker's wigging on fire
and next thing you know i'm selling
[__] tickets to shows i was
but you gotta remember one thing there
were people that did not like me and ari
for years they would ask rogan why do
you bring these two losers on the
[__] road
and all that [__] so this was part of
the reason i wasn't getting nowhere with
stand up
i'm not gonna lie to you guys for
[__] 20 years nobody talked to me
from 91 to 2010
i couldn't even get a [__] booking
agent nobody would talk to me about
stand up
meanwhile i'm at the store tearing their
[__] hearts out
every [__] night so i think i left
the store in 2007.
i was at that store tearing [__]
lights out already
from 2003 on i had already started
clicking
i had already started rocking and
rolling especially at the store
the improvs knew i was rocking and
rolling i was kind of co-headlining
or whatnot but i didn't [__] stop
my commitment was that much i mean
am i mad at myself for it no i'm here
i i got to where i wanted to be i got to
the league
where i wanted to be you know i never
wanted to be kevin hart i never wanted
to beat david chappelle
i just wanted to be a regular comic and
at least somebody say he's [__] funny
and maybe maybe do like a stand-up
comedy routine i would have been [__]
satisfied with that i swear to god
because i didn't feel like i was worthy
of getting all this [__]
i'm a [__] felon i'm a petty [__]
thief
all of a sudden i'm [__] you know
people want to take pictures with me
people want to get my autograph i'm like
what the [__] is going on don't these
people know i kidnap somebody
what the [__] is going on so this was
all new to me so
when 2010 came along and once that story
went
it just [__] snowballed thank god
thank god that before mercy was born
i took a self look at myself and i said
you know if i'm gonna be a father
i gotta do this i gotta do that i gotta
do this
i gotta be this way i gotta stick to my
word and i [__] did it
but i couldn't do it before i did it
because i was older
now i can see listen i can see a move 20
steps ahead now
i see a move 20 [__] steps ahead
that that you know when you get older
and you go through a [__] life like i
did
you could see the next 20 steps when
somebody comes up to you
with their first three words you already
know where this is going
and for me that's what happened with
comedy like i already knew
the [__] steps you know i already was
in it
but i let myself go i let myself go in
ways that
today i got to pay for like today you
know when i wake up
if you don't think i'm doing [__]
sit-ups every day even with this bad
[__] leg
you're out of your mind i do my sit-ups
i try to do [__] push-ups off the
[__] couch
i do everything i can to stay in shape
and to stay healthy and to keep my heart
you know today i did the club match a
little bit of club match you know
i can't do long because the recuperation
i run out of breath my cardio
you know this [__] one month of being
down has really [__]
uh i go for a walk around the [__]
corner i'm [__] winded
but at least i'm [__] trying but what
i'm trying to say to you is that
don't get caught up that much on what
you're doing do not forget your life
and do not forget who you are i didn't
forget who
i was i didn't forget who i was i didn't
change i didn't become a movie star
i didn't stop talking to my friends none
of that should happen with me
it was i just stopped taking care of
joey i didn't take care of joey
whatever you decide on doing nothing is
as important as you
are as your health as your hobbies
as what brings you [__] joy you know
and
comedy brought me joy for a long time i
i still love it
going on stage and meeting different
people
but that's the only regret i have
was that when i went in i went in just a
little too hard
and i forgot about a lot of [__]
things
and then years later it came back to
haunt me like i got no friends
you know all i have is com the last
three or four years in la
i had a little sadness towards me yeah
lee was my friend but he's 30 years
younger than me 20 years younger than me
i had friends you know i had great
friends and ari
and dean and but they weren't the
friends i had here
this is what i needed again i needed to
get that
jersey friend you know you [__] with me
i'll [__] with you mentality i didn't
come to jersey
because there was a problem or anything
like that i came to jersey because
the dream was done i had done everything
i wanted to do in comedy
and it was time to [__] move on it
was time to
do something different you know i i
still love doing the [__] podcast
i still love talking to you guys i love
doing the patreon i love answering you
guys on social media
i think with the stand up i'm just a
little upset with myself that
like i just forgot who the [__] i was
you know like
and now coming back and seeing that i
made a whole football season
over there at florentine it's just it
it's like i want a [__] medal
like i want a medal for attending all of
them and having a great time and let me
tell you what
really surprised me about sunday over
there
i was over there i was having a great
time my wife and daughter went to a
different super bowl party that's not a
place for
kids over there we're talking [__]
there's no pot smoking or nothing they
drink now i'm the only [__] pot
smoker
there's one guy i put edibles in his
beer
every week i go and i just every time he
goes to the bathroom i put a [__]
edible
in his beard 25 milligrams 25 milligrams
25 milligrams one week i put 125
milligrams in
hash tabs and 100 milligrams in one of
those [__] abx capsules
and he still [__] walked out of there
for three weeks in a row i dosed this
guy
and he didn't complain not one [__]
time
one time he came over to me one then he
goes hey
did you give me something last week did
you put something in my beer last week
or something i go no
why would i do that he goes man i got
home last week after football
and i sat down and he goes i was
starving
but i couldn't get up to cook dinner i
couldn't even get myself
up to cook dinner i don't know what was
wrong with me finally he goes i took a
little nap and i got up about 9 30 and i
was fine i cooked dinner
he goes i could have sworn you but me
and jimmy florentine were [__]
howling
because every time he gets up to go to
the bathroom i run over to the can and i
drop some minute and you actually hear
the pill hit the bottom it goes kink
and we just [__] die it sounds like
the [__]
when they put the when they took the
braces out of my [__] knee those
little think
think think that's what it sounds like
i'll sit right behind him
and the game is right over there and i'm
right here by the back
sliding door and every time he gets up
to go to the bathroom
i put a [__] little edible on his
[__] beard and then once i'm done i
leave
and i wait to hear something the next
day but i don't hear nothing
and the best is jimmy's brother takes
the poor guy
him and his other friend and they put
bumper stickers on his car
and it's like i like sucking dick you
know if
if you want a blow job hunk and they put
it on the back of their cars and they
don't realize
it's on the back of their cars to like
[__] the points day
these are [__] hilarious guys this is
what i'm talking about
this is no [__] no fake oh my god
none of that stuff these guys none of
them play that [__] they just play
[__] tricks on each other
they gamble they [__] drink and they
have a great time
they say [__] that's out of this [__]
world the world i came from where you
could just say whatever the [__] you
want
and nobody's feelings get hurt or you
know one time i think i went after i
left
there was a fracas a woman went down
there and they were [__] torturing
her
yeah it's not woman friendly either it's
it's it's guy friendly and i had
forgotten all about that thing
so just me going there every week on
sundays
just brought me back little by little
little by little they had me gambling
you know when the last time i put a
better last time i put a bed in was diaz
mcgregor
that was the last time i [__] put a
bed in and a couple of weeks i [__]
put bets and i told you guys like in
september i was putting bets in
and winning small bets i wasn't betting
over my head 25
just to watch the game just entertain
yourself and watch the game this week
i went over there early and i helped set
up the pool
and they had like a big pool and a
little pool and like i said i said you
know
when was the last time i got in a
[__] pool i mean this is the [__] i'm
talking about these are the little
things
that i was not doing in la that [__]
sucked dick
like one in my pocket i took 30 dollars
i go give me [__] whatever
it's five dollars a box give me six
boxes i almost had the first quarter
when it was three nothing
i almost [__] had i had three and
zero and then [__]
grunk scored a touchdown or whoever
scored a touchdown
i think it was gronkowski whatever his
[__] name is
and then i left a little before halftime
my wife called me and said i'm picked
because i can't drive so my wife says
we're leaving now i'm going to come get
you
the kid you know my daughter to take a
shower and whatnot
and uh she dropped me off ov i came home
i got home about 6 30.
and when i got home i told my wife i go
if it wasn't for that
football on sundays i'd still be hiding
under the [__] couch
i still would i wouldn't even have done
the podcast because i was so [__]
scared of koben
abc [__] news that david visser that
[__]
he had me so [__] fired up about
[__] coven
and i came here and i was even more
petrified because this is where it
[__] started
it started back here and now it's big on
the [__] west coast
but it started back here march 9th i
guess that that was the week when i was
supposed to come
so i'm really happy that uh that was one
of the things i wanted just to talk
about man that no matter how much you
love something you gotta have a [__]
life
you gotta have a life you know i can't
[__] stress enough
it's like these people on the computers
on the weekends
when i go on twitter on saturday just to
check messages or something
and there's people yucking it up on
twitter on a saturday and sunday it
breaks my [__] heart
it breaks my heart you got to give it a
breather
you got to go out you got to take a walk
you got to see friends you gotta
you know for years all i did was [__]
planes trains and automobiles
so now on the weekends that's the last
thing i want to [__] do
you know i let me tell you something
like i told my wife last night
how long you know me tyree i go out
every [__] night if i want to go out
i'll go out
you know just for me to go out at night
you know how many nights i go tonight
i'm gonna go see this guy perform
at the stress factory i don't even have
the desire to [__] go out
i'm excited about next friday and
saturday doing stand-up on my birthday
and uncle vinnie's i'm excited about
that i'm excited about
what i'm gonna do is this i'm gonna do
those seven shows
and then i'm gonna decide where i'm at
in my head
if i want to go on the road i'll go on
the road
if not i'll just treat stand up like a
hobby
and why why do you think i'm doing this
because
i don't want to bomb on the road i hate
bombing
i'm not in business for you to pay
thirty dollars to see me [__] bomb
and i've been writing the book lately
i've been every [__] day i write a
paragraph or two
i write ideas for the upcoming chapters
i've got it outlined i've always
outlined three chapters before uh
i don't even know what the [__] i was
gonna say but you know i have ideas and
i've been writing and stuff but
when i [__] you know i i write on a
[__] ipad
and i have a comedy notebook right next
to it and i'm just writing about like
jokes about the surgery
i'm just trying to write about what i've
been through the last [__] two or
three or four months
and i'll tell you what the next day when
i look at it
there ain't nothing funny in those
[__] jokes not at all i mean i laugh
a little bit but it's not that
so what i'm gonna do is this i'm gonna
do these
you know my wife said that maybe the
problem is that sister shows us
somebody else is telling me this dead
since the audiences
are smaller it's tough to really gauge
and that's why you really don't like it
but
that's just i could tell you that lie
also that's not what's bothering me
what's bothering me is that i did my job
i burnt out
i just burnt the [__] out i did my job i
did it as hard and as best as i could
i put everything i had into those
[__] things you know
when i did those stories for aries those
stories were great but they're not great
because they wrote themselves
i had to [__] sit down and write them
and you know
it's a process comedy is a [__]
process and it's a lot of work and i put
the work in
and i hope that what i'm going to do is
this i'm going to do those seven shows
at vinnie's
i'm going to listen to the recordings
i'm going to see how i feel
and then making my decision if i'm not
ready in april then i'll just take the
[__] summer off
and i'll get on stage when i'm ready you
know if
jimmy or rich have a show and i want to
do a guest spot
i'll jump in on that the sopranos the
many saints in newark comes out in
september
you know that would be the ideal time
for me to go out after that
let's see how i [__] feel you know
right now this is
the truth of the matter the truth of the
matter is i did something that i thought
that me or nobody else thought could be
done
i never thought i would see myself in
the position i saw myself
selling out the chicago theater selling
out the theaters in new york selling out
parks casino
you know i really appreciated it but i
never saw it in my
future not at all i was very surprised
that all that [__] [__] happened so
in my world let me tell you something
this wasn't supposed to happen
i wasn't supposed to last to 58
i was not supposed to [__] you know
like i told you guys every night when i
walk into my daughter's bedroom
because my daughter goes to bed at nine
i go up there by 9
25 and give her a kiss and tell her i
love her she shuts
she puts on a little [__] car map at
9 30
and then i go back there about 10 30
and i just look at her while she's
sleeping and i and i try to grasp
what has happened in my life and how i'm
living in a [__] twilight zone
this was not supposed to happen i see
myself in that [__] rocket ship
sleeping in that [__] rocket ship and
i'm like how could this be possible
that i am living in new jersey i have a
great wife who loves me and i love her
she's my partner in crime
and i got a [__] beautiful daughter
and i had a daughter that doesn't talk
to me
we stopped really having contact with
each other like i left her when she was
five
and i picked up right off it's like
nothing [__] changed
nothing changed but where i'm at today
i never saw myself i saw myself doing
comedy till i od'd
or died on the road or something you
know
i didn't see myself being 58 with a
beautiful [__] daughter and a house
and a beautiful wife and
having my choice on whether or not i
want to do comedy
i mean i just i'll get a job i don't
give a [__]
i'm ready for something else like i'm
just ready for something else you know
uh if you guys listen to rogan you heard
my ads
on spotify they finally i'm doing ads
for rogan the
draftkings so i'm excited about that
uh you know i'm doing things that just
are keeping me busy right now for where
my head is at i'm not ready to fight
you know it's funny i was talking to lee
and lee said
lee's in florida uh you could support
him on patreon he's doing a great job
he's trying his heart out uh he went to
florida the other night and this is very
interesting
lee said that he walked into a
restaurant with his dad
and there was a hundred people easily
with no mask on just sitting there
eating and he
he said that he hadn't he leaves like
i don't get anxiety attacks but i got an
anxiety attack and i go what do you mean
he goes
i couldn't sit there that was the first
time i had seen 100 people
since [__] march he goes i almost had
a [__] heart attack so
last week the ap did a poll
and they were talking about people
[__] you know
what people think now that the vaccine
is that
do you know that [__] like 40 percent
of people said
that they feel comfortable inside even
with the vaccine
people still don't feel [__]
comfortable people there's a ton of
people
some that you do know some that you
don't know i know a handful of people
that have not even left the [__]
house since the pandemic started
i can name five [__] i know on
the personal
that have not left their house since the
pandemic so
if i know five [__] people we all
know people
we work with people maybe you haven't
seen them because you have you don't
work with them
maybe they haven't left the house
there's other people that are living
their life
like there's nothing out there i god
bless you i don't give a [__] how you
live your life
i just want you to be [__] healthy
but lee said it was too much for him
like he
wasn't even prepared he said he grabbed
his dad and he goes we got to take it to
go i'm not ready to be around 100 people
so that's the same with us you know with
me what am i gonna do
the first time i go out there and see
300 people on a [__]
stage i'm not going back to theaters i
doubt they're gonna put me in a [__]
deed and i'm gonna do you know
half of those people people are broke
right now you know half of the people in
new jersey don't
got their [__] unemployment checks
that's going on all around the [__]
country
they're talking about these stimulus
checks coming out but these checks ain't
coming out
people are [__] hurting how do i know
because every week i get a call i send
out money
you know i try to help my friends i got
20 friends that are [__] having a
hard time right now
i have comments you guys know that when
i get the patreon [__] check
i start sending out little [__] uh
paypals to friends of mine that i know
that i know they're [__] missing
meals they don't have to [__] ask me
i know what they're going through i knew
what they were making
you know so i don't mind because you
guys are helping me out on the [__]
patreon so
i pass it on this is this is what we do
we got mike we got
you know i still haven't donated the
[__] the thing yet i'll do that
tonight
thank you for reminding me it's the
[__] tent i want to make a donation
to uh
barstool sports he's helping out [__]
businesses
you know i love to [__] be a part of
that and for your names to be a part of
that so if you check it it'll be on the
jose diaz
it won't be on the [__] uh whatever
the [__] will be under my name people
like we didn't see the church on there
no stupid it's on the hose ideas
ah one of my friends called me you guys
remember him keith herron
i donated every year to him and one year
he's like uh we didn't see it i go
do you look on the jose diaz it's not on
the church
it's on the jose diaz that's my [__]
name that's the name of the credit card
when you go to those gofundmes and [__]
you can't pay you got to pay with
[__]
or you know you could do paypal i don't
know how we got to this
but anyway back to sunday's [__] game
i'm sitting there last week and i'm like
i'm like i said i
i didn't know what was gonna happen i
just knew
i loved tom brady but i also loved the
quarterback from casey i think he's
[__] talented
he's young he knows how to read defense
as well
i think he's [__] phenomenal so i
couldn't pick a quarterback so i
couldn't pick a side
so when you have that dilemma you're not
forced to gamble
that's what i love about gambling on
football
that you're not forced to gamble on a
team even baseball
even basketball you have the over and
under for people who don't know the over
and under
the over and under there's a score that
they put that the score is either going
to go over that
or under that so let's say the over and
under is 50 in a football game
for it to go over somebody has to be 28
25 that's 53 points that means it's over
if you go under the 50 that means it's
you know
24 [__] 10 and then
it goes under so that's the difference
between an under and then over
they have them in baseball they'll put
like seven and a half home runs
they haven't been basketball you know
180 points i don't know what the
the over and under is for that sunday
night i haven't looked yet
but i'll uh i won't tell you now because
i have a computer in front of me
who the [__] gives a [__] sunday is
sunday
today is [__] wednesday and all i'm
[__] worried about
is tonight baby when [__]
who is this i have yeah miami houston
look at that [__] line this little
[__] who bots
problem with that [__] line i like
looking at the lines the lines tell you
everything
and lately i've been betting little bets
on basketball and i'm not doing bad
either
i haven't been doing bad i talked to the
philly godfather last night
he's the guy that gives you pics and we
were talking about different things and
[__] like that
and i told her i go if you ever bump
into something good give me a call
i'll pay you i don't give a [__] i'll
pay for a [__] pick
because i kind of enjoy it now like i'm
gonna watch the lake again valentine's
day what do you think i'm gonna [__]
not watch it now now i got
now i'm back into watching stuff you
know everybody i
can't watch tv though don't ask me what
my show is because i don't [__] have
one
i did watch the denzel movie on hbo
with jared leto i don't know what the
[__] happened there i
i don't know two people i talked to said
they watched it
and they didn't understand that i i
didn't even know it was jared leto until
he was not over in or some [__]
you know i watched uh the the other
gandolfini movie the other night
i'm a movie guy i watched death wish the
other night [__] tremendous
you know i'm a movie guy i can't i don't
have time to watch a [__] series on
netflix and nothing like that i
i don't even have the [__] focus to
that that's the real [__]
answer to it but that was it sunday
my whole plan was to wake up and bet the
total
but my day got out in front of me i had
to do something with the family in the
morning
and by the time we had to go to freehold
and by the time we got back
i just had to drop me off at [__]
jimmy's and uh
and i didn't you know but the one thing
that really surprised me
and the same reason i'm doing what i'm
doing is this guys
let's say i'm a greedy [__] let's say
i'm a gavon
and i don't give a [__] about you guys
i'm gonna go out on the road anyway
yeah it's just gonna be a money grab i'm
gonna retire in two years
it's just gonna be a money grab i'm just
gonna go out charge a ton of money for
the tickets
and go up there and i don't give a [__]
what comes out of my mouth i can do that
if you want me to
i don't have the balls to do that i
don't have the heart to do that if i
want to rob you i'll get a [__] gun
you understand what i'm trying to say to
you i don't want to go out as a [__]
loser
i want to go out as remembering selling
out the vegas
theater selling out the tempe improv
selling out two shows in atlanta i don't
want to do comedy till there's 13 people
in the audience
and i'm a pathetic old man up there i
hope you understand where i'm going with
this
i just you know that's why i'm really
surprised
brady didn't [__] retire sunday
you want to go out of [__] on top you
know what i'm saying i'm not saying that
i'm kevin hart
i'm not saying that i'm dave chappelle
i'm not saying that i'm joe rogan
but dog for what i did
with what i had and where i came from
and the problems i had i did pretty
[__] well
you know even i have to take a look and
go joey you have nothing to be upset
about
you made it to tv you got a couple
[__] movies
you got to sell out some big [__]
venues you had a nice run there
you have nothing to be upset about i
have nothing to be upset about
in fact i'm [__] proud of what i did
so i'd rather stay proud
this way than for me to say [__] these
[__]
charge them 45 go out there
go up there do improv not give a [__]
about what
what you do and then you guys leave and
you're gonna say what
[__] joe rogan's a liar he's not the
funniest guy in the world i don't want
that to happen
so i will never do that to you i'd
rather not go out
than go out because to be a [__]
gavon and [__] you guys in the ass
if that's what you want you're looking
for you're looking for it from the wrong
[__] guy
i want to go out like [__] tom brady
i want to go on
winning a [__] super bowl and in my
world i won a super bowl
i made it to the comedy store
documentary i [__]
you know did all the accomplishments i
guys
when i got into this it was just a check
out
it wasn't to be successful i didn't
think
i could ever attain success at anything
i tried
and that's 100 honesty from the [__]
heart
i didn't think i could get anywhere in
this [__] world
i thought i would just be a feature act
and it was better than [__] robin
houses and dine in a [__] prison
so to me i'd rather go out this way
i'd rather go out you remember me seeing
me in vegas and going
[__] he ripped that [__] room apart
i'd rather you go out saying bro i saw
that [__] in the store one night
and it was [__] scary i'd rather you
say [__] and i saw him in the main room
and it was [__] scary i saw him in
cleveland i saw him in new york
i'd rather you say that than say [__] we
went to see joey diaz
that's [__] pathetic that's what i
don't want that's what scares me
the most when i first got into this
business that was my biggest fear
of being 50 years old
nobody's going to hire you and you're
[__]
going from club owner to club or hey how
you doing
you know do you think you got a night
for me there my wife you know
i i didn't want to be an old comic in
search of
that was not what i was going for so i'd
rather go out this way
if i go out who the [__] knows who the
[__] knows what i want to do
the sopranos comes out september 24th
september 25th uh the mini saints of
newark
and that might put a bug in me that
might spark me up to do it again
you know i was waiting to do a clooney
movie in february here
i'm waiting on law in order to organize
crime i haven't heard nothing so
listen i put it in god's hands if god
wants me to be in it i'm in it
if not [__] it i don't belong in it
that's how i look at it so
that's why i'm i'm making my decisions
like that
i want to go out like a [__] man i
don't want to go out up on stage [__]
sweating because i'm dying of [__]
jokes
[__] all that nonsense you want to walk
out on your feet
not walking on your [__] knees like a
mutt and a half
and that's it for the wednesday [__]
podcast man
we had a little chit chat we got the
talk we got to see each other
that's it and that's that it was a good
[__] week
you know my leg is making a [__]
comeback but it's been a month
the anniversary was [__] monday of
the surgery
i still have [__] pain it's not
excruciating pain
you know uh i still got to take the pain
medication
i've cut it down by 50 percent
you know i'm uh doing [__] the leaves
now because
i got to get off this pain medication i
mean i just got to get off this
pain medication i'm down at two tabs a
[__] day probably now so
uh we made it nobody got hooked nobody
got [__] [__] up
you know that was my biggest fear about
this was getting hooked on the pain
pills but
obviously i've been hooked on so many
[__] things there's no other things
left for me to get hooked on so [__] it
i just keep smoking my reefer
keep eating my cbd lion and i [__]
make it through this [__] you know what
i'm saying that they're working against
the heroin what's that
yeah we'll do some heroin in time and
time
i don't i was telling somebody the other
day mike
i don't think i could do anything
anymore
like i'm just done like i can't ima
like i have 13 years of sobriety of
cocaine
and it's not really sobriety it's called
fear
like it's fear of cocaine because i know
if i do a line of coke i'll die of heart
attack
if i do a line of coke right now i won't
come back
i've always known that because i made a
promise i made a man's promise
if i do a line of coke i won't come back
i can't see myself doing [__] heroin
i didn't like the first couple weeks of
how these these pills made me feel
it's been uh it's been a really weird
switch for me like who i was and who i
am now you know you know it's just yeah
we just changed and i tell you
i'll tell you what i've been smoking a
lot less too
good though tremendous well the problem
is this
i'm over here from california and i'm
smoking these [__] joints
okay the weed i get there's no need to
smoke joints
you don't need a whole joint you smoke
half the joint and you're sitting there
going what am i gonna do with this
[__] thing
that's why it's called one hit weed i
went i bought a [__] pipe
and my life changed i smoke a pipe in
the morning when i get up for the
breakfast appetite
i smoked a bowl when i got back from
physical therapy
around 1 30 and guess when i smoked
tonight
about a quarter to 11 right before miami
vice
if miami vice sucks
[__] i play the weed if it's good
then i [__] you know i'm saying
nobody loses
but i'm not even smoking as much as i
was
he sent me another shipment of abx i
love you know i love justin over at abx
i love those [__] tablets and i had a
you know
what i don't take them in the daytime no
more look at my eyes look at my face
look though you could see my [__]
eyes they're white
i don't take them no more i use those
edibles as sleeping pills
i use those edibles and sleeping pills
yesterday i posted
on twitter i posted my monthly box from
uh on it i get shroom tech
i get alpha brain for my cycle i'm gonna
start a new cycle here
on the 15th which is next monday
i get the protein bites for nighttime
[__] that an apple
your brand new seven grams of protein
when you get stoned
i'm not that's why i'm not [__] dog i
was eating those [__] ten chicken
cutlets and
pizza no more i get the protein bites
the peanut butter ones
excuse me or the coconut almond from on
it
oh tremendous the [__] chocolate
almond
nut protein bars or the [__]
uh peanut butter from on it at night
if i get hungry after the tea i [__]
eat an apple and i get a little protein
seven grams of protein i think it's 100
calories
and i'm brand new i take the [__] i
take the
abx i put them in the [__] kika moti
kikamo has two grams of thc five grams
of cbn
sometimes i put two bags of tea in there
if i really want to sleep hard
i put two bags of tea in there i put
like
why lie 400 milligrams
because my man my man told me that the
hundreds
were stronger than the 200s my man
[__] mike is always paying attention
mike calls me up he's like man i think
these hundreds are strong in the 200s
so i said let me try it holy [__]
i put four hundreds in a cup one night i
couldn't even [__] breathe
i woke up i told you like this my arm
was up
i woke up like all twisted with the cup
in my [__] hands like this
i woke up like a four in the morning
like why am i [__] twisted
jesus christ there was an inch of tea
left in that [__]
i went to taste it it was colder than a
[__] ice cube
i had been asleep for like five hours
holding the cup
with my arm up on the [__] lazy boy
so i use those i i use because i had to
switch my time zone
so i stopped doing yeah i was falling
asleep at four in the [__] morning
so i said [__] it what am i gonna do so
i got off the edibles completely
i got clean and [__] sober off the
edibles and now i use them to go to
sleep at night
for those abx's and a couple [__] you
could use kikomo tea
or you could use what's other uh
lemon tea from not lemon zinger but do
you have
you ever tried lemon zinger oh that
shit's got extra caffeine in it
but they got a cousin sleepy time it's
made in longmont colorado the company
i get one little sleeping time teas and
i'll throw four edibles in that oh my
god
one night i ran out of one night i ran
out of the [__]
one night i i ran out of the abx's
and i got like eight of those [__]
hem
the hashtags and i put them in the
[__] tea and it was the worst tasting
thing
i ever drank in my life it tasted like
rotten miso soup
i drank the whole [__] thing like a
soldier listen i sleep like a baby why
i spray the melatonin in my [__]
mouth from honey you got a problem
sleeping get the melatonin from on it
and it also melatonin is good to fight
against [__] covid
so remember what i'm telling you that ah
you heard that from uncle joey
i spray the [__] melatonin i put the
four tabs in my [__] this is what i
need to fall asleep and that is a tank
i put four tabs in a [__] tee
i put three or four [__] tinctures
of either tommy chung's
tommy chong has a good little sleep uh
potion he gave me his his buddy gave me
the
a thing i either go with cbd lion
or [__] put you down but you got to
move them around
because your body adjusts to melatonin
your body adjusts to all this sleep [__]
and then you're just sitting there not
asleep
so every night i gotta go from somewhere
different so some nights i just do the
kick-a-mo
some nights i do the cbd lion some
nights i do tommy chong's little [__]
contraption that he gave me
some nights i do the [__] abx some
nights i do the t
to confuse me it keeps me [__]
confused
so i never because if i do uh
melatonin three nights in a row i won't
[__] sleep what's the other thing
that they use that's in turkey
tryptophan i have tryptophan too so i'll
switch it around you know me dog
you got to play tricks on yourself you
know what i'm saying don't forget
chance out of respect for the chinese
people i ain't mad at you
i forgot all about kobe who gives a [__]
we're here with queer
it's [__] wednesday and we're moving
straight ahead
i love you [__] with all my
heart thank you very much for supporting
me here
thank you very much for supporting me on
patreon and thank you very
much for just supporting me at all
coming to shows whatever the [__] you do
like i said this weekend draftkings is
on fire
[__] valentine's day this weekend
don't forget to give your wife a [__]
gift
you know ladies if you're looking for a
gift it's not too late to get manscaped
so he could shave his balls and his
[__] and put that ball right in your
[__] mouth for valentine's day
who needs chocolate when you got a nice
set of [__] balls
just dip them in hershey's chocolate and
dip them in her [__] mouth
and that's it that's the best
valentine's day you'll ever [__] have
i love you [__] stay black have
a great [__] week
whatever's left i love you [__]
with all my heart thank you for all the
support
and now for a word for my sponsors
oh real quick zeke [__] what do you
think about that
they sent me a little t-shirt if you're
in the [__] la area
do not forget to go to urban trees tell
them uncle joey sent you and they'll
[__] hook you up
tell them you want the [__] peanut
butter cups from [__]
zeke tell them you want the [__] i
pay what you get from zeke i see
i love you [__] stay black have
a great weekend
don't forget about draftkings don't
forget about cbd
lion don't forget about stamps.com don't
forget about me i love you [__]
have a great weekend stay black
all right you guys thank you very much
for listening today
it's a shitty [__] uh wednesday but
what are you gonna do it's cold outside
at least you're listening we had a nice
little hour chit chat
and whatnot before we go let me talk to
you about a few things
let's face it taking trips to the post
office ain't how you want to spend your
time
that's why i recommend stamps.com send
letters ship packages anytime anywhere
right from your [__] computer
and you pay a lot less with discounted
rates
from usps and ups and more get the
services of the post office and ups all
in one place
plus big discounts let me tell you
something my wife has been using
stamps.com she [__] raves about it
she tells everybody she knows
to use stamps.com they bring the post
office and
ups right to your computer you got a
business
this is a must-have print us postage for
any letter any package any class mail
anywhere you want to send then schedule
a pickup
and the mailman comes to you or drop it
off yourself it's that simple
with stamps.com get discounts up to 40
percent
are you listening to me 40 of the post
office rates and up to 62
offer ups shipping rates that's a lot of
[__] stamps right there
stamp.com is a no-brainer it saves you
time
and it saves you money no wonder a
million small businesses
already use stamps.com so stop wasting
time
going to the post office go to
stance.com instead
it's no risk and with promo code joey
you get a special offer that includes a
four-week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale no
long-term commitment to contracts
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
and type in joey that stamps.com promo
code joey
stamps.com never go to the post office
again
the joint is also brought to you by from
the heart of new jersey
draftkings the [__] best you
understand me i forgot to tell you about
this weekend in the super bowl and all
that [__]
but [__] draftkings is always there
they make gambling
fun they have prop bets boosts
you know they have special i mean they
do it
all if you want to play cards if you
want to bet on sports
they got you covered listen this week is
special tonight dm you got the nba
tonight
but sunday night is valentine's day and
the la the la versus denver game
draftkings has got some [__] a deal
for you and a half that you're gonna
love
this is better than any [__] box of
chocolates if you're like me you're
looking for any opportunity to get
better eyes correct
okay we'll look no further if you place
a bet on sunday night's basketball game
you will single-handedly lower the over
and under that's some [__] love right
there for every thousand players
who bet the over on sunday night's game
the line will drop by one [__] point
the best part is that even if the line
lowers
the odds remain at even money that's
right
it's called hammering the over you can
double your [__] money right now
at draftkings if you ask your hometown
booker to give you that action
he'd shove a poke you up your [__]
ass if this isn't enough excitement for
you
there's a huge title fight on saturday
night
usman versus the little [__] pitbull
that's gonna be tremendous the undercard
is degrade
and they got great odds and promotions
on basketball hockey
and so much more all week long but the
party starts tonight
draftkings is safe secure and
reliable get your guidance when you want
tonight you got a great game you got
miami
versus [__] houston the line's a
little weird on this one and i got some
info
on the memphis versus la game on friday
night
so there you have it uncle joey's even
throwing love your [__] way
who's better than draftkings nobody so
download the top
graded draftking sportsbook app now
today
use promo code joy when you sign up to
hamilty over
on sunday night's basketball game when
la takes on denver
for every thousand people that bet the
over in sunday's game the line will
decrease by one point
you listen to what i'm saying to you so
this is a chance to improve the odds of
hitting
of the overheating so tell your friends
your family when you go to church on
sunday
[__] you know peace be with you
kneel over and say draftkings.com
[__] hamilty over
go right now right now go to sportsbook
go to the draftking sports book app
and that's promo code [__] joe you
tell everybody you know because the more
people going on this
the lower the line gets and you still
double your money here's the legal
[__] [__] i gotta tell you ready
you gotta be 21 or older give me a
breather new jersey indiana michigan and
virginia only
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details do you have the
gambling problem
call 1-800 gambler or in indiana 1-809
with it or in virginia
888-532-3500 but if you don't have a
problem
it's time to hammer the [__] over
with code joey a draftking sports book
app
right now download it and tonight's your
[__] night open up tonight
tonight's your night to win some money
the joint is also brought to you by
my [__] the love of my life [__]
cbd lion
what haven't they done for me during
this [__] surgery between the tape
the tincture the roll-on i mean come on
give me a [__] breather i was doing
the gummies i switched to tincture
this week i'll go back to the gummies go
to cbd lion
and go to the cbdlion.com go to the
website
read read read learn about cbn
learn about cbd and how it controls your
body how could it
how it affects your body and what they
have
to solve your riddle if you have back
pain
go to cbd lion they have certain
products that work for certain things
that's why i love them go to cbdline.com
right now and press in
joey or church and get 20 off your order
delivered right to your [__] house i
want to thank cbd lyon
i want to thank draftkings i want to
thank stamps.com
for a great week of podcast but most
importantly i want to thank you
[__]
thank you have a great weekend and see
you monday morning
tip top [__] magoo happy
valentine's day i love you guys
take a hike
[Music]
so
you